*Techno Music*
The name's Flagmaster 64
I'm a level 3 YouTube hero.
You work hard to make YouTube better for everyone...
I do work hard on my videos.
But now I'm gonna work hard-like never before
I'll make it better for everyone
I'm not the hero that Youtube needs,
I'm the hero it deserves.
When I first became a YouTube hero
It was the happiest day of my my life
Almost like being a real youtuber
But without putting in any of the effort
*Hitler making a speech in German*
So Herr Fuhrer with our level 3 flag system
Don't you think people might abuse that?
*German Dialogue*
Fine bros
What do you have to say?
The confusion and negative response over what this all is has been so overwhelming.
But again with this one and all these
It's very, very complex
And we also know there is so many more questions
Oh wow I didn't realize you were the ones that came up with this system.
YES!
*Youtube Hero Video*
*Jack's vids getting flagged*
*Jacksepticeye playing in background* *Typing Noises*
Youtube heros...
It seem that all youtubers, absolutely  hate this new feature
But do they really?
Right now at this point, shitting on YouTube is just generating views...
So that's just what people are gonna do.
I would never shit on YouTube for views
[Sarcasm]
Just look at leafy
The end of YouTube is here, the death of YouTube
Now that seems a little exaggerated don't you think?
Maybe just a tiny little bit?
I mean would never shit on YouTube for views that's just against my core principal and core message
Take your hand off me
*Fighting*
Do it...